hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
near the end of chapter 17 of his
treaties on the anger of God locked
Pontius is going to provide us with a
definition of what he calls just anger
and it's very straightforward you know
he's using the Latin term Eustis in this
case
right so the kind of anger that would be
appropriate and why is he doing this
well because God who does get angry has
just anger towards those at whom he
feels and displays that anger and
LaChance is going to be contrasting this
against all sorts of mistaken
understandings of anger and the Divine
that focus on unjust anger and use
wrong-headed definitions ultimately
coming from philosophers now he's going
to get there by considering the first of
of all action of God the octopus what it
is that God does and he says that
um you know God is not asleep he's not
dead uh he's not at rest and he you know
this is attacking the the views of of
some other philosophers who think that
God really doesn't do anything or the
gods don't do anything and then he says
to himself
that what can the action of God consist
in and here he talks about the
administration of the world and the
Latin term there is actually
Administration right taking care of
running regulating making sure that
everything goes right of the Mundus the
the world the entirety of the universe
and he'll use the word care or Kura
right and he'll tell us that God cares
about not just the world as a totality
but also specifically human beings right
hominess and the life of human beings
not just human beings in the abstract
but the actual lives that people live
and this extends to individual actions
of these human beings he uses the word
singular right for for those but we can
translate that as individual so he's
he's a god who's got a lot on his mind
so to speak right and he goes on and he
tells us that um
he earnestly desires that human beings
should be wise and good he wants human
beings to be like him I mean human
beings are made in the Divine image as
lactancius is going to discuss in other
places and so he wants us to be as you
know close as we can to God in terms of
wisdom and goodness and that includes
justice as well so la tancius goes out
and says this is the will the voluntas
of God this is what God desires wants
chooses for human beings and he gives
this as a law which lachtancius is going
to call Divine Law and eternal law and
so God then is actually moved by anger
by the feeling or emotion or affection
of anger against those who now notice
this not just those who break the law
also those who despise or show contempt
for this law and so you know there's
going to be some anger arising pretty
necessarily but why is it because God is
just jealous no it's because God wants
the best for human beings as you know
like conscious will say in other places
anger and care or beneficence go
together for God and so um
he goes on and he says it's necessary
that God should be moved with anger
against the person who's broken this if
as he says God does harm to anyone
therefore he's not good they are
deceived by no slight error who defame
all censure whether human or defined
with the name of bitterness or malice
thinking that a person ought to be
called injurious who visits the
injurious with punishment so he's taking
on a possible objection somebody might
say well God is supposed to be you know
really nice all good he wouldn't hurt
anybody right and interestingly he's not
just taking on let's call the merely
moth Christians he's also taking on the
epicureans who says gods don't do that
sort of thing right
so here locked on CS is going to employ
an interesting analogy he's thinking
about God not just in terms of being a
judge he talks about that as well you
know we don't condemn all judges for
engaging in judgment and Punishment
right why would we do that with God
he actually thinks that a better
metaphor might be the owner and ruler of
a household he says
I would ask from those who represent God
as immovable if anyone had property a
house a household of servants and the
servants or slaves despising the
forbearance of their Master should
attack all things and themselves take
enjoyment of his Goods if his household
should honor them well the master was
despised by all insulted and deserted
could he be a wise person who would not
Avenge the insults but permit those over
whom he had power to have the enjoyment
of his property and he says that's not
really forbearance that is insensible
stupor that's not a laudable state of
view right and he says to Pardon Deeds
of this part is actually not kindness
but cruelty why because you're you're
letting things be disordered you're
allowing those people not just to take
your stuff but they're probably going to
be doing damage to other people as well
and then he says so the world is as it
were the house of God and human beings
as it were his slaves and if his name is
a mockery to them what kind of or amount
of forbearance is it to give up his own
honors to see Wicked and unjust things
done and not to be indignant which is
peculiar and natural to him who is
displeased with sins and here your
locked on CS is going to say something
very very interesting to bring that
analogy to a close he says to be angry
therefore is the part of reason
for thus faults are removed
licentiousness is curbed and this is
plainly in accordance with Justice and
wisdom so anger in this sense in the
right way is actually tied in with these
two things that are recognized as not
just virtues but also Divine attributes
Justice and wisdom so how do people get
so mixed up about this lockedancius
blames the philosophers which you know
he thinks they they were you know
sometimes on the right track but they
were missing some information they
needed and often got things mixed up so
you know he talks about two schools in
particular the stoics and the
aristotelians and he says the stoics did
not see a distinction between just and
unjust anger they think it's all unjust
so I mean you can look at Seneca or
Epictetus or Marcus Aurelius and their
remarks about anger and get a good sense
of that what about the aristotelians
well octanius here refers us to his much
larger work the Divine institutes where
he actually talks about the
aristotelians at length he says you can
read that book The aristotelians Go
Wrong by thinking that you just moderate
anger you know anger is fine provided
that you feel the right amount of it and
you kind of curb the excesses of it but
you do need it for other stuff and you
know is this the the full Aristotelian
view on anger Ah that's debatable right
but it it probably was a popular
conception that people were using at the
time and he says why do these schools go
wrong both of them are ignorant of the
true nature of anger and so you know
they produce wrong definitions of it
what are these wrong definitions he says
uh
Seneca enumerated these in the books
which he composed on the subject of
anger so if you've read seneca's on
anger these will be familiar to you he's
citing him there anger is he says the
desire of avenging an injury others as
posedonius the great stoic philosopher
says describe it as a desire of
punishing him by whom you think you've
been unjust unfairly injured some have
defined it anger is an incitement of the
mind to injure him who has either
committed an injury who or who has
wished to do so Aristotle's definition
which he's getting from Seneca in this
case because this is not the definition
from rhetoric book two anger is the
desire of requiting pain giving pain
back in response and so um locked
hansius is going to say these are all
definitions of anger but of unjust anger
not of just anger
and he says this is something that you
know we have in common with the beasts
uh and we should restrain it in human
beings otherwise we could come to some
very great evil through rage so you know
no problem with this but this is not the
kind of anger that God is going to feel
and this is not the kind of anger that
just people are going to feel so what is
that he says you know the just and good
person is going to be displeased at
seeing evil done they're not going to be
tranquil they're not going to pretend
that it's not evil they're not going to
like brush it under the rug they're not
going to turn their back on it they're
not going to be you know uh unduly uh
forgiving and weak and and meek with it
they're actually going to be upset about
it they're going to feel anger and
they're going to be moved by that anger
he says uh you know where is that just
anger against offenders this is
evidently not the desire of Revenge
right he says that you know I speak of
uh the people who are you could say
under our purview and he says that
um we arise to take Vengeance not
because we've been injured not because
it's hurt us as such but because we see
wrong being done and there are purposes
behind this he talks about
preserving discipline disciplina right
order proper structuring and preserved
as a servata right to maintain to hold
on to
morals in this translation corrected but
the morals are actually mores which
doesn't just mean like the public
declaration it means what's in people
the the
um not just feelings and nor worms but
also habits that people have Morris
names that Dimension and then
licentiousness repressed uh
licentiousness going too far with things
you know all sorts of things lost greed
uh gluttony we could go on and on and on
which would also
the licentiousness that comes from
unjust anger
so this uh is is quite important he says
that uh this is just anger and it's
necessary for human beings for the
correction of wickedness so manifestedly
it is necessary in God from whom an
example comes to human beings
as we ought to restrain those who are
subject to our power so also ought God
to restrain the offenses of all and in
order that he may do this he must be
angry lachtancia says and so here's a
definition that we can give anger and
now the English translation here is a
little bit
misleading it's an emotion well it's
really a motion a motus which takes the
the shape of an affect right as we find
out later in the treaties so an emotion
of the Mind arousing itself or rather
you know arising arousing in surrogantis
rising up right uh in order to do battle
uh for restraining
for the purpose of restraining or to the
the function of it
false picata Piccata can be translated
also as sins faults errors mistakes
wrongs it's the things that that we do
that are unjust so anger is an emotion
of the Mind arousing itself for the
restraining of faults and he says that
you know he concludes this one by saying
the definition given by Cicero anger is
the desire of taking Vengeance does not
differ much from those already mentioned
the wrong-headed ones and then he says
but that anger which we may call either
Fury or rage shouldn't even exist in
human beings because it's all together
vicious but
the anger which relates to the
correction of vices
ought not to be taken away from human
beings
nor can it be taken away from God
because it is both serviceable for the
Affairs of human beings and necessary so
just anger should be there unjust anger
shouldn't be there and just anger is in
God and can also be in US human beings
and now we know how to rightly define it
so we can grasp its nature